[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
صعود شجره التصعيد الميداني لا يشبه فيما
يبدو النزول منها هكذا اوحت المواقف
الاخيره للحكومه الاسرائيليه لمن قرا بين
سطورها نبره مختلفه تشي في تقديرهم
بموازين قوى فرضت التحدث بمنطق بمنطق عفوا
بمنطق تراجع فييه منسوب الاستعلاء العسكري
صحيفه يدعو ت احرنوت الاسرائيليه قالت ان
اسرائيل تنتظر خلال الايام القليله
المقبله رد حماس عبر الوسطاء القطريين
بشان صفقه الرهان واضافت الصحيفه ان
التشاؤم يسود في اسرائيل بشان الحصول على
رد ايجابي
والتقييم الامر سيتطلب ضغطا عسكريا بدا
المشهد في نظر تحليلات سياسيه وعسكريه
دورانا في حلقه مفرغه صحيفه ول ستريت
جورنال الامريكيه نقلت عن مستشار الامن
القومي الاسرائيليه السابق مائير بن شبات
قوله ان لدى حماس ثقه الان لرفض اي صفقه
لا تمنحها النصر الرجل كان افصح واسرح من
المسؤولين في حكومه نتنياهو عندما قال ان
ظروف عمل قواتنا اصبحت اصعب بينما تحسنت
ظروف حماس هي التوازنات القتاليه على
الميدان قد فعلت فعلها مع بث المقاومه
الفلسطينيه مزيدا من التسجيلات التي تثبت
بالصوت والصوره تتالي الضربات الموجعه
التي تتلقاها القوات الاسرائيليه الغارقه
في اوحال غزه في الاثناء تترقب تل ابيب
زياره لكبير الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكن الاسبوع المقبل عنوانها العريض
مجددا تدارس التطورات وتقليب الخيارات
ازاءها معنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في
الاستوديو اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي من الناصره الدكتور
مهند مصطفى الخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه
ومن فينا المحلل السياسي حسام شاكر اهلا
بهم جميعا ا لواء فاس دويري اهلا وسهلا بك
كنا نتابع المؤتمر الصحفي لاسامه حمدان
وتحدث فيه ب بكثير من الاطمئنان على ان
المقاومه تمضي بكل قوه واقتدار وان محاوله
القضاء عليها هي اضغاث احلام
وسراب يبدو هذا النوع من الخطاب يكرس
انطباع الان يسود تدريجيا بان الامور
الميدانيه ليست في صالح اسرائيل وبان
المقاومه تكتسب المزيد من الثقه في النفس
نعم بكل تاكيد يعني اتفق معه الى ما ذهب
اليه ليس لانه هو من تحدث به لكن لاني
اتابع بصوره يوميه وعلى مدار 83 يوم من
عمر هذه المعركه و59 يوم من المعركه
البريه السؤال الذي يجب ان يطرح من وجهه
نظري واجيب اقول ماذا حقق الجيش
الاسرائيلي في البعد العسكري تحديدا لانه
اذا تحد حدثنا في الابعاد الاخرى سينتهي
وقت الحلقه البعد الاجرامي وتدمير البنيه
هذا امر اخر البعد العسكري حتى اللحظه
التي اتحدث بها ليخرج ها جاري ويرد علي
يقدم الي انجاز عسكري واحد بالامس كان
هناك نوع من الحديث السا هم يقولون قتلوا
عناصر عديده من حماس يقولوا ما يقولوا هذا
الرد عليه سهل بالامس تحدثوا بنوع من يعني
بغض النظر عن المقاربه قبل اسبوعين قالوا
بانهم حصلوا في
بيت شقيقه محمد ضيف على صوره الهويه
بالامس صحفيه على احد القنوات الاسرائيليه
تقول تم العثور على حذاء السنوار وبالتالي
اقول لقد حققتوا اهداف وبامكانكم الانسحاب
اذا كانتم تسعوا الى اهداف لكن هل هذا حد
هل هذا هدف الهدف الادنى لدى الجيش
الاحتلال والقياده السياسيه انقاذ الرهائن
اليست هي الان محور الحديث السؤال هل
استطاع بعد 59 يوم من المعركه البريه ان
ينقذ رهينه واحده
بمقاربات انت اشرت له نقطه ايقاع خسار
الان نتحدث عن 83000 طن من المتفجرات القي
على غزه يجب ان يكون هناك خسائر كما هناك
خسائر في الجانب المدني في الجانب العسكري
لكن السؤال ما هو حجم هذه الخسائر انا لا
لن ادخل في لغه الاعداد لاني لا املك لغه
الارقام حتى اتحدث ولا تحدثت بها اقول ما
دامت المقاومه قادره على اداره المعركه
بنجاح وبتحسن وب منحنى صعودي اذا حجم
الخسائر لم يؤثر في الاداء نحن نتحدث عن
عشرات الالاف من المقاتلين لو كان هناك
قتلى او شهداء في المستويات العليا ل ل
تثر القياده اذا دعني اقول لم
لم تضعف حماس قد يتساءل ويرد علي البعض
اين الصواريخ الان هذه مقاربه لمن يدير
المعركه يطلق الصاروخ بالاتجاه الذي يشاء
في الوقت الذي يشاء الى الهدف الذي يشاء
انا لا اعلم ذلك لكن اقول بما انه بين
فتره واخرى يتم انجاز هذه المهمه وهي
الثغره الوحيده التي تناقش الاجابه موجوده
في البعد الميداني انت اشرت الى
الفيديوهات و
بالتالي ال لا تزال رغم فارق القوه الذي
لا يمكن تجاهله ان يد القسام لا تزال هي
العليا في ارض المعركه من البعد العسكري
في المقابل دكتور مهند
مصطفى قليله هي الاصوات الاسرائيليه ومع
ذلك مهمه عندما ياتي ايدان كلدان وهو رئيس
منظمه المحاربين القدام المعاقين ويقول
بالضبط وهنا انا اقتبس يقول لم يسبق لي ان
رايت نطاقا ولا كثافه لاصابات الجنود مثل
هذه يعني لم يرى في في حياته وهي المنظمه
هذه مسؤوله عن عن 50 الف جندي اسرائيلي
اصيبوا في في الحروب السابقه لم يرى بمثل
هذا الشيء هل هل تعتقد بان هذا سيكون له
ما
بعده نعم يعني واضاف الى ذلك استاذ محمد
ايضا الخدمات الصحه النفسيه سواء كان في
الجيش الاسرائيلي او كانت في منظمات
المجتمع المدني الاسرائيليه التي اعلنت
انها تتلقى توجهات غير
مسبوقه ل الصحه النفسيه بسبب بسبب هذه
الحرب سواء كان بين صفوف الجنود او في
داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي لا شك انه كل هذه
الاحداث والتطورات من الاخفاق العسكري من
الخسائر البشريه من الخسائر
الاقتصاديه ادت الى صعود اصوات كانت في
البدايه صامته كانت في البدايه الدايه
خائفه ليس فقط صامته كانت خائفه في
البدايه لانه كان هنالك في حال من التفكير
القبلي لا يقبل اي نقد لا يقبل اي خلاف لا
يقبل اي راي مختلف عن الراي المهيمن وهو
الاستمرار في هذه الحرب والقضاء على حركه
حماس حتى موضوع الاصر والرهائن اصلا لم
يكن مطروح في في بدايه الحرب الان نسمع ان
هنالك في اصواتا مهمه جدا صحيح انها قليله
ولكن تاثيرها الشعبي تاثيرها الجماهيري هو
كبير جدا جدا انا اتحدث عن اصوات قادمه من
المؤسسه العسكريه يعني عسكريين سابقين
وليس برتب منخفضه وانما برتب عاليه انا
اعطي مثال التصريح الذي قاله دان حلوتس
وهو رئيس هيئه الاركان الاسرائيلي السابق
الذي قال نحن خسرنا هذه الحرب وان صوره
الانتصار الوحيده لنا هي الاطاحه ببنيامين
نتنياهو يعني اذكر هناك الكثير من
التصريحات من سياسيين مثل اهود اولمرت
الذي قال يجب وقف الحرب و وا تحقيق فقط
اعاده الاسرى والرهائن الاسرائيليين وهذا
هي صوره الانتصار بالنسبه لاسرائيل ولذلك
هنالك في صعود لاصوات مختلفه في داخل
المجتمع الاسرائيلي طبعا الصوت القوي هو
صوت
الاسرى صوت صوت العائلات الاسر والرهائن
الاسرائيليين كل هذه الاصوات تدل ان هنالك
في طيار يتصاعد يتوسع في داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي يستانف على هذه الحرب يستانف
على اهداف هذا الحرب واولويات ويبدا يطالب
بالتفكير من جديد بهذه الحرب وانا اريد
يعني ان احدد بعض الامور المهمه في هذا
التيار اولا ان اسرائيل لن تستطيع يعني
هذا التيار يقول كالتالي اسرائيل لن
تستطيع تحقيق الهدف المركزي الذي وضعته
وهو القضاء على حرقه حماس هذا الامر اصبح
في اسرائيل يعني تقريبا شبه منتهي لا احد
يتحدث عنه بجديه لا احد يتحدث عنه انه
قابل للتحقق هذا ليس فقط من يدعو الى وقف
الحرب حتى من يدعو الى الاستمرار الحرب
هنا هنالك في تساؤل ما المقصود بالقضاء
على حركه حماس النقطه الثانيه هنالك في
اخفاق استخباراتي كبير جدا في اسرائيل
اخفاق استخباراتي قبل السبع من اكتوبر
الان يعني اصبحنا نعرف اكثر واكثر عن هذه
الاخفاقات واخفاق بعد السبع من اكتوبر
المتمثل في عدم تقدير قدره حماس والامر
الثالث هو المطالبه
بالاطاحة وفق ما ذكرته القناه الثانيه عش
الاسرائيليه سيبحث فيما وصف بمقترح قطري
لتبادل الاسرى والرهائن والمحتجزين لم
يسبق ان ان طرح من من قبل هل تعتقد بان ما
يجري على الميدان بالضروره دفع نحو صيغه
مختلفه قد تكون
اكثر لصالح المقاومه منها لصالح التصورات
الاسرائيليه التي كانت
تريدها نعم في الواقع نحن نتحدث عن تطورات
في الميدان مهمه وهذه التطورات لها انعكاس
تفاوضي يعني ندرك فقط بان قياده الاحتلال
انتقلت من اليقين المفرط بالذات بانها
تستطيع انجاز المهمه في قطاع غزه الى حاله
الشك في الذات المعلنه وايضا تضييع الهدف
الجوهري الذي اعلن سابقا تحت عناوين جديده
اليوم الحديث ليس فقط عن غزه تقول قياده
الاحترا على لسان جالانت نفسه بانه نقاتل
على سبعه سبعه جبهات وهذا يعني بانه لا
توجد نقطه تركيز واحده بهذا المعنى
وبالتالي يمكن تمييع الهدف مع الوقت وايضا
تفسير حاله التاخر الجاريه في انجاز
المهمه والتعثر وبالتالي توجد سرديه الان
تتشكل في مجتمع الاحتلال او قياده
الاحتلال تساعد نسبيا في النزول عن الشجره
يوجد توجد قناعه بانه لا يمكن انتزاع
المكاسب بالتفاوض السابق الطريقه السابقه
ولكن ايضا ايضا ال في غزه توجد شوكه لم
تنكسر وبالتالي تستطيع ان تفرض شروطها
استبعد اليوم ان تنجح اي عمليه تفاوضيه في
موضوع تحرير او تخليص بعض الاسرى في كما
كان السابق هدا مؤقته هذه وصفه في تقدير
لم تعد ممكنه واقعيا وتبين بانها مقدمه
لمزيد من الفتك والقتل لكن المساله
الاساسيه ان قياده الاحتلال والخبراء
تابعون ايضا في داخل فلسطين وخارجها
يعلمون بانه ثمه اندفاعه اسرائيليه في
الميدان نحو المجهول والمجهول يزداد قتامه
ترتفع الفتور ترتفع الكلفه ضريبه التحرك
وثم التاثير ايضا نتوقع في الايام المقبله
هو دخول السنه الجديده عندما يستشعر الناس
في العالم تستشعر الحكومات الداعمه لحمله
الاباده بانه دخلنا سنه جديده دون انجاز
حقيقي مع ارتفاع هائل جدا في الكلفه
الاخلاقيه في التكاليف المعنويه في الضغط
الجماهيري في تقدير نتحدث عن مرحله مختلفه
عما كان في قبل الان ثم تعثر الازمات بدات
ترتد الى عمق الاحتلال يوما بعد يوم كلما
زاد هذا العدوان زمنيا تزداد الكلفه على
الاحتلال على مجتمعه على اوساط على جيشه
الان يتحدث صحيح كبار القاده الذين هم
لديهم ميول معارضه للقياده الحاليه ح
وسياسيا لكن ستزداد هذه النبره في
الاعتراضات وتزداد مع الوقت ايضا افصاحات
عن حجم التعثر الميدان نعم مثل ما تابعتم
على الشريط العاجل بعد نهايه هذا البرنامج
وبالتاكيد مع بدايه نشره التاسعه هناك
كلمه جديده لابي عبيده الناطقه باسم كتائب
القسام حصلت عليها الجزيره ايضا ستتابعون
بعد قليل ربما هذه الاوضاع الجديده اللواء
فايز الدويري عندما تبعنا قبل قليل السيد
اسامه حمدان تحدث عن ان الحركه منفتحه على
مقترحات لوقف ال العدوان كما قال ولكن لا
قبول باي وقف مجزا او مؤقت
ل اطلاق النار هناك بيان صدر عن مجموعه من
فصائل المقاومه ايضا يكرس نفس الانطباع
وهناك ايضا تاكيد من رويتر بان هناك رفض
من حماس والجهاد لمقترح مصري فيما يتعلق
بصفق في صفقه على مراحل وايضا القناه
الثالث العشره الاسرائيليه تقول بان حماس
رفضت ايضا مقترح اسرائيلي امريكي جديد
والليله سيناقش مجلس الحرب مقترح قطري هل
تتوقع اننا نقترب اكثر من تصور ربما اقرب
لتصور المقاومه يعني دعني اقول اولا يبدو
ان موقف المقاومه لا يزال ثابت فيما تقديم
التنازلات الان بدات من الجانب الاخر موقف
المقاومه من خلال متابعاتي اجد يترخص في
عده امور
اولا قبل الحديث عن اطلاق سراح راء هائ
وهو الحد
الادنى يجب ان يكون وقف اطلاق نار
شامل الرهائن تحت عباره واضحه الكل مقابل
الكل يضاف الى ذلك هناك 80,000 ما بين
شهيد وجريح غير الذين لا يزالون تحت
الانقاظ هذه الدماء هي ليست مياه القيت في
الشارع لها ثمنها وهذه تعتبر جزء من ثمن
الحريه اذا يجب ان يكون هناك وقف اطلاق
نار مقابل الكل مقابل الكل رفع الحصار
اعاده الاعمار انشاء اعاده انشاء المطار
الذي دمرته وتوسيع الميناء هذه اعتقد هي
طلبات المقاومه ولغايه هذه اللحظه هي
متمسكه بها بينما الجانب الاخر يعني لدي
معلومات قد لا تكون انه يستجدي الان
الجانب القطري تحديدا بان يضغط على حماس
لقبول بعض المقترحات وتقديم بعض التنازلات
وهذه معلومه حصلت عليها وهي غير رسميه لكن
يمكن يمكن اعتمادها يمكن اعتمادها بناء
على التغيرات في الموقف الاسرائيلي
والخطاب الاسرائيلي في الداخل اذا هناك لا
يزال ثبات في موقف حماس هناك تقديم
تنازلات في النهايه سيكون تقديم تنازلات
متبادله لكن يجب ان تخرج حماس منتصره امام
شعبها بعد الثمن الذي دفع ولكن المشكله
دكتور مهند مصطفى يعني هل هل هناك قبول في
الشارع الاسرائيلي او في المؤسسه العسكريه
والامنيه لاي صيغه تظهر حماس بصوره
المنتصر هذه يعني هذه يعني لقمه اك اكبر
من الفم الاسرائيلي حتى
تبلع نعم هذه هي المعضله الاسرائيليه
الكبيره في هذه الحرب اسرائيل في هذه
الحرب وبالذات المؤسسه العسكريه والامنيه
الاسرائيليه ومن ثم نتنياهو يريدون صوره
انتصار مقنعه للمجتمع الاسرائيلي بدون
صوره الانتصار المقنعه ليس فقط ان هنالك
تداعيات استراتيجيه كبيره على اسرائيل
هنالك في تداعيات على العلاقه تاريخيه على
العقد الاجتماعي بين المجتمع الاسرائيلي
وبين الدوله بين المجتمع الاسرائيلي وبين
الجيش الاسرائيلي ولذلك اسرائيل تبحث
بتلهف عن صوره نصر تقدمه للمجتمع
الاسرائيلي ولذلك هنالك ما زال في داخل
المجتمع الاسرائيلي مساحه اكبر مساحه اكبر
تعطي المؤسسه العسكريه بالاستمرار بهذه
الحرب اريد ان اؤكد ان هذه المساحه هي اقل
من المساحه التي كانت موجوده مع بدايه
الحرب هي في حاله تقلص في حاله تراجع ولكن
ما زالت هذه المساحه موجوده حتى هذه
اللحظه اسرائيل تدرك والجيش الاسرائيلي
يدرك ان انتصار حماس في هذه المعركه هو
ليس فقط يعني تمس بالعقد الاجتماعي بين
المؤسسه العسكريه وبين المجتمع الاسرائيلي
انتصار حماس بشكل واضح في هذه المعركه هو
ضربه استراتيجيه غير مسبوقه لاسرائيل في
على مستوى موقعها الاقليمي على م على
مستوى قدرتها على الرضع على على مستوى
يعني قدرتها المستقبليه على على على
مواجهه خصومها واعدائها ولذلك كل وقت نسمع
من سياسيين اسرائيليين يعني حتى اليوم
سمعنا من بني جانس الذي قال ان حتى
المرحله القادمه سوف تفاجئ حماس و وبالامس
تحدث بنفس بنفس الصيغه انا اعتقد انه هذه
التصريحات تاتي في سياق رفع معنويات
المجتمع الاسرائيلي بالذات على ضوء تصاعد
الاحتجاج الكبير في داخل المجتمع على هذه
الحكومه بالذات فيما يتعلق بملف في الاصر
والرهائن يعني دعني هنا افرق بين امرين
مهمين جدا الامر الاول ان المجتمع
الاسرائيلي يريد هدنه ومستعد ان يدفع ثمن
كبير جدا لهذه الهدنه ويمكن ان ان ان
يوافق على هدنه طويله الامد فقط من اجل حل
مشكله الاسرى والرهائن انا في اعتقاد ان
حركه حماس تدرك ذلك ولكن المشكله ان هذا
المجتمع لا يريد ان تكون هذه الهدنه هي
نهايه الحرب لا يرد من هذه الهدنه ان تكون
نهايه العمليات العسكريه ولذلك المعدله
الاسرائيليه الحقيقيه في يعني في هذا
الشان ان انها تدرك ان حركه حماس واعيه
لهذا ال المزاج الشعبي والسياسي في داخل
اسرائيل ولذلك هي مصره على عدم التوصل الى
اي اتفاق لتبادل الاسرى بدون وقف نهائي
لاطلاق النار التعويل هو استاذ محمد ان في
المرحله القادمه المجتمع الاسرائيلي سوف
سوف ينتقل من هذه المرحله الى مرحله جديده
وهي يعني هي الان في حاله تشكل صحيح انها
متواضعه ولكنها في حاله التشكل بشكل كبير
جدا الانتقال الى مرحله ان المجتمع الاسي
سوف يطالب بوقف هذه الحرب ليس فقط من اجل
الاصر والرهائن ولكن ايضا بسبب الازمه
الاقتصاديه بسبب الواقع الاجتماعي الداخلي
الانقسام الداخلي في اسرائيل يعني هذا
موضوع مهم جدا اسرائيل تعيش حاله انقسام
داخلي في زمن حرب في زمن حرب غير مسبوق في
تاريخ اسرائيل غير مسبوق غير مسبوق ويهدد
التماسك الداخلي الاسرائيلي بشكل بشكل غير
غير مسبوق والاهم العامل الاخر هو عدم
الثقه
المتواصله ببنيامين نتنياهو يعني نتنياهو
حاول كل الوقت ان يعيد هذه الثقه ولكنه لم
ينجح هنالك عدم ثقه بنتنياهو كل هذه
العوامل المجتمعه سوف تؤدي بالنهايه في
تصوري من الانتقال من حاله القبول
بالهدنيا الاسرائيليين شرحت هذه المعضله
الاسرائيليه ولكن الا توجد ايضا معضله
امريكيه اوروبيه معضله غربيه بشكل عام
سييد حسام شاكر لان اذا
كان
هزيمه اسرائيل في مثل هذه المعركه وتفسير
الهزيمه بالطبع
له مفردات وتفسيرات مختلفه اذا كان يشكل
ضربه استراتيجيه لاسرائيل كما ذكر وايضا
ضربه استراتيجيه للولايات المتحده لاوروبا
لكل ما كان يوصف بالعالم الحر بين قوسين
وهو الذي وقف مع اسرائيل بالكامل في هذه
الحرب بطبيعه الحال نحن لابد ان نذكر هنا
بانه الجانبان بان الجانبين الامريكي
والاوروبي القيا بالثقل الكامل في هذه
الجوله وكنا نتحدث عن اوكرانيا هنا الجانب
الاخر بانه الانجاز لم يتحقق في الميدان
الكلفه الاخلاقيه هائله المده تمتد هذه
لها كلفه بطبيعه الحال وسترك اسئله والاهم
ايضا غياب الدبلوماسيه الدبلوماسيه
الامريكيه الدبلوماسيه الاوروبيه بالذات
غائبه عن المشهد منذ شهور وبالتالي لماذا
غابت اين هي الحلول التي كان يمكن ان تعرض
عندما تصرفت اطراف اوروبيه باعتبارها طرفا
في هذه الحرب هذا يعني انها عطلت الدور
الدبلوماسي القادر ربما على التدخل في
لحظه معينه وبالتالي هذا زياده في الازمه
جانب اخر هو ان الاحتلال سوق ما يجري على
انه معركه مصيريه نحن او هم وبالتالي
عندما يبقى هم اي الفلسطينيون ثابتون في
غزه ثابتون على الارض وتحت الارض هذا يعني
ان الاحتلال يقول انتهيت انتهيت امام
جمهوره امام العالم هذه السرديه ذات السقف
المرتفع التي اريد منها حشد العالم حشد
الجبهه الداخليه في هذه الحرب ترتد على
الاحتلال الان بانه غير قادر كما قال
دكتور مهند غير غير قادر على ان ينزل عن
الشجره ويقدم انصاف خيارات ربما للخروج من
هذا المازق وبالتالي هو مندفع الى مزيد من
الوهم الى مزيد من المازق لانه لا يملك
حاليا فرصه الخروج من الميدان بشكل كريم
وايضا يدرك ان مزيد من التورط في غزه يعني
مزيدا من الخسائر الميدانيه والفجوه الان
تتعاظم بين ما يقوله قاده الاحتلال ما
يقوله ه جاري وما يرى في الميدان الغزي من
مشاهد مرئيه تقدمها غزه تقدمها فلسطين
للعالم ولجمهور احتلال وبالتالي الازمه
حقيقيه لداعمي هذه الاباده الازمه حقيقيه
لاداره امريكيه هي تريد ان تتفرغ لحمله
انتخابيه بينما تجد نفسها مرتبطه بشكل او
باخر ليس فقط في غزه ولكن في اقليم ملتهب
مرشح لانفلات الاوضاع وبالتالي اوروبا
ايضا عندما تدرك ان التجاره تتاثر بما
يجري عبر البحار ان الاقليم يمكن ان يلتهب
في اي وقت المعادله تخرج بشكل ما عن
السيطره لكن من زوايا غير محسوبه حسب
توقعات غير محسوبه وبالتالي الكلفه هذه
سيكون ستكون ضم غطه حقا سترتفع وترتد على
الدول تحالفت مع الاحتلال في هذه الحمله
وبرتها بطبيعه الحال نعم ربما حتى لا تخرج
الامور عن السيطره اللواء فايز الدويري
هناك زياره مرتقبه ل
بلينكن نهايه الاسبوع وهي زيارته الرابعه
او الخامسه سيزور الاردن السعوديه
الامارات قطر اسرائيل الضفه الغربيه ومع
ذلك لا يبدو ان هناك تغير جذري في في
التعا الامريكيه هنا فقط استشهد بما كتبه
دينيس روس المبعوث الامريكي
السابق للشرق الاوسط مقال له في وول ستريت
يقول محاوله ارغام الاسرائيليين مثلا على
القبول بدوله فلسطينيه هذا سيعطي نتائج
عكسيه هو لا يقبل هذا النوع من الضغط اذا
كان هذا هو التوجه لا نضغط على اسرائيل لا
نريد احراجها لا نري ان نجعلها في مازق
اذا الامور لن تتغير يا سيدي يعني من قبل
الهزيمه على نفس نه قد يقبلها للاخرين الم
تقبل امريكا الهزيمه في فيتنام وخرجت
بصوره مذله الم تقبل الهزيمه في افغانستان
الم تقبل الهزيمه في الصومال الم تقبل
الهزيمه في العراق الا الا تحاول ان تتخلص
رغم المكاسب الاقتصاديه من الباديه
السوريه كما يقال اذا دعني دعني اقول انه
امريكا قد تقدم تنازلات حتى هذه اللحظه
هناك البعض الموجودين يعني الم يقل بلينكن
انه جاء الى اسرائيل كيهودي وليس كوزير
خارجيه اذا هناك من يفكر بعقليه نتنياهو
لا يزال ولكن الوقاعه على الميدان هي التي
سترغب الجميع على تقديم التنازلات واختم
واقول من يقبل الهزيمه لنفسه سيقبلها
للاخرين على ذكر الاوضاع ل الميدان لواء
فايز الدويري المحلل العسكري ل يدعو تحنو
رون بنشي وهو يعني مشهور يقول هذا التقسيم
مرحله اولى مرحله ثانيه مرحله ثالثه هذا
يقول التقسيم نحن الذي صنعناه صنعناه
واختراع نحن اخترعنا فقط لارضاء الامريكان
ومحاوله
التخفيف علينا من الظ انا قلت سابقا ان
هذه المراحل وتجزئتها لا تنسجم مع
المفاهيم العسكريه التي التي درسناها
ودرسناها هذه هي فقط عمليه تجزئه بما يخدم
الخطاب الموجه للداخل واقناع الجانب
امريكي باننا حققنا انجازات ولدينا الان
تحول لمقاربات اخرى لكن ثق ان ال
العمليه جزئ ام لم تجزئ لم لن تستطيع ان
تحسم الواقع الميداني شكرا لك لواء فايز
الدويري شكرا لك دكتور مهند مصطفى وشكرا
جزيلا لك سيد حسام شاكر بهذا نصل الى
نهايه حلقه اليوم موعدنا يتجدد باذن الله
غدا في تمام الثامنه ونص بتوقيت mk